give me this child the ceos i'm glad we
started with mufasa because the news
ain't so
pretty
the ceos of several i'm talking with the
giraffe of several european blue chip
companies have told cnbc that they see a
significant recession coming down the
pike in europe
it's coming
but so in europe
of course it's coming everywhere there's
going to be a global recession we
already have a global recession underway
now
anthony what do you know about
we're gonna have a global recession
underway the reason why we're gonna have
the global recession is because every
central bank around the world has been
let me put her out there that's what
we're gonna do this is what she likes to
do right now the reason why we're gonna
have a global recession is because every
single central bank in the world has
been relatively devaluing their fiat
currency
and those fiat currencies now are so
cheap and so devalued so debased that
there's no other option that we have if
you're going to continue to devalue
currencies and as you devalue those
currencies you then get all of the
increased asset prices you get inflation
you get all these problems now they have
to increase interest rates but at the
same time that they're increasing
interest rates and tapering on all the
asset purchases what's going to end up
happening good you wanna bring her
outside all right look at this oh sofia
is in trouble she got taken off the show
she got taken away and good that's gonna
be bad all right so the reason why the
recession is basically inevitable is
because as they begin to ease
oh polina doesn't know that she has the
microphone on uh and so as the recession
continues to play out here you're
getting contraction but the reason why
the contraction is happening is because
the fed has to stop uh stimulating the
economy if they continue to stimulate
the economy they're only going to push
inflation higher and higher so think of
it as almost like a balloon if you're
pumping air into a balloon you're
pumping air and you're pumping air and
you're pumping air in the balloon gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
if you stop pumping air in what happens
it either stops or if you don't have the
end of the balloon plugged
it deflates that's all that's happening
to the economies they've been pumping
air into this bad boy and now all of a
sudden you're getting the deflation
of the economy or the contraction of the
economy so that's what's occurring and
not only are they going to continue to
do this they actually are going to
accelerate it they're now basically
saying we're going to take the balloon
and we're going to squeeze the air out
of the balloon we're going to continue
and pushing the air out and so when that
stuff occurs you just get to a recession
faster and of course they're going to at
some point after reverse course i think
by the end of the year we will have an
interest rate cut we'll see how it plays
out but uh definitely not going to be a
good situation for anyone okay
sophia's out there in good hands
maybe in february peloton ceo john foley
stepped down and cut 2800 jobs
now
peloton is looking to sell up to a 20
stake amid its market sell-off struggles
there's carnage everywhere like i think
that i think that's what everyone needs
to uh uh understand right is that the
carnage that is out there is so bad
right now
that every single company over the last
five years that got overextended they
took on a bunch of money they started
hiring a bunch of people they thought
everything's gonna be great forever
they now are like oh [ __ ] we gotta cut
our cost
and so there's companies slashing 20 30
40 of their staff we know startups that
are cutting their executives literally
going and saying oh you're the head of
product you're the cto you're out we
gotta cut cost and so peloton
not only already cut costs but now
they're saying [ __ ] we need more money
on top of the cost cuts so what you're
about to see is a bunch of technology
companies both in the public markets and
private markets it's gonna be a rough
time and when it's a rough time it means
job cuts that means that people are
gonna go to the capital markets
investors with cash are salivating right
now because if you've got cash you're a
price maker not a price taker if you're
a startup you ain't got cash you're a
price taker ain't gonna be so hot for
you i wonder what's gonna happen to all
the peloton instructors who are making
500k a year
like they go they they're they're the
last ones to get fired you think yeah in
terms of like the best ones yeah because
they're the core of the business they
are the product
right
facebook is shutting down its podcast
service and discontinuing other audio
products facebook podcast i didn't even
know that's what i was going to say i
actually knew that they had one do you
remember we had this on a lunch money
last or last year about um how like they
were trying to compete with clubhouse do
you remember this yeah i do remember
this uh uh hold on a second i am uh
y'all good
out there he's not there oh he's not
there all right i'm trying to see who
makes sure uh sofia is okay this is dad
life right now uh-huh you good out there
making sure that you know there's no uh
it feels so bad no collateral damage
going on out there but yeah didn't even
know facebook had uh audio the only
reason i know is because they keep
trying to put our podcast on facebook uh
and we didn't and so
it came it went if a tree falls in the
forest and no one hears it did it exist
i don't know so
at the end of the day facebook has got
to focus and focus is a super power to
them uh and so their ability to say what
are we doing that is uh uh
not working well uh
facebook's podcast service is probably
one of those cut it focus on the things
that you can do and let's get going
absolutely
so
mercedes
um
mercedes is
wait hold on in collaboration with ftx
the cryptocurrency exchange
mercedes f1 cars will adorn the rear
wings of both lewis hamilton and george
russell's cars with special designs from
artists mad dog jones and it's an nft
i like this and i don't like it why do
you like it i think that this is really
cool because they're gonna donate
everything to charity is my
understanding yeah uh i
that's why i like it i don't like it
because it feels like you don't need the
nft part of it why because if you just
want to auction it off like just go
auction it off but i think they want to
be it's the same reason gucci
accepting crypto understand they're
playing into the the crypto world i get
it but it just feels like uh it's
gimmicky
a little bit a fact now now with that
said it's gonna work they're gonna raise
a bunch of why they're gonna give it a
charity i'm on board right they're doing
good so like i get it but uh i do think
that it's uh uh a little bit of a
it's like why do you need the nfd well
don't you again like i don't i i think
it's more of an awareness thing
because oh i understand the business
case extreme
but isn't it good for crypto is my
question my here's my whole thing is how
i think about like nfts and stuff is
that uh
there's a new piece of technology that
now ex new right whatever
what can you do now that you previously
couldn't do yeah that's where all of the
value is going to accrue yeah just
taking something that you could already
do and doing it with nfts yes you will
get some short-term things like this
but that is not going to uh uh be
anywhere near as valuable as doing the
new things that now are possible because
of this technology and so you could have
easily auctioned off things in the past
yeah i just don't think it's that big of
a deal okay all right next
what the hell is going on in shanghai
do we know
well the ccp is an authoritarian
government well first of all all these
people have been you know
in lockdown for five weeks with you know
without food and all this stuff now six
people are under investigation after an
elderly nursing home resident was
mistakenly declared dead put in a body
bag and then they're like oh my god wait
this person's alive there's a video of
it went viral
the guardian i mean everybody's writing
about it it's absurd
it's crazy why do you want my you want
my real take what
in the united states there was plenty of
people who were categorized as uh uh
virus-related deaths that maybe didn't
there's
a lot i know but there was a famous case
in florida where somebody got killed in
a motorcycle accident but get counted as
a uh
that is awesome that's what i'm saying
it does because what you end up finding
is whether they're miscategorizing
things or literally they're saying oh we
have five body bags here that person's
alive like ends up happening is if
people aren't paying attention or
people are doing malicious things it
ends up being pretty bad
all right it's ask lunch money time
hashtag ask lm in the comments below
uh tori wells asks what do you think
long-term results will be if we continue
with inflation and recession how will
this affect our country what will you do
personally to prepare great questions
tori what do you think um so i think uh
the long-term results i think i mean if
we're heading into a recession i think
there's going to be continue to be
carnage in the public markets as well as
i think it'll be hard for private
companies to raise money 2020 and 2021
were great for them great years and now
it's kind of catching up so hopefully
you were fiscally responsible with your
cash so now you don't have to worry that
much but how will it affect our country
i mean i think you know if you're a good
business you'll continue to be a good
business i think it'll get rid of some
of the fluff the kerfuffle no that's
that's not the right word kerfuffle is a
fight
okay um anyway what do you think in
terms of what somebody should do to
prepare for a recession yeah
durability that's the number one thing
how or can you be durable cash and cash
flow
that's it if you think about when a
recession comes think of it like a fight
you're training all summer long you're
just fighting uh you're hitting the body
bag you're sitting there you're lifting
weights you're running you're doing
sit-ups push-ups the whole thing you're
training you're training your training
that's what we've been doing for the
last five six seven eight ten years
good times get strong
now all of a sudden
here comes the recession it's time to
fight and the people who are ready who
have cash who are durable with cash flow
etc they're gonna be ready to roll
people who don't
that's exactly right you're so hot that
is that is true all right go get sophie
okay bye guys as y'all could hear she's
crying she's so excited right now